Штрольху 9 років,
а бавиться, наче цуценя.
У Німеччині його називають "Straßenhund" - безпритульний пес.
Але лише тому, що його господар Гайке живе на вулиці.
- Відтоді, як він у мене є, я значно щасливіший.
Тому що… хтось є поруч…
Завжди є хтось, хто дбає про тебе.
Про Штрольха, схоже, теж добре дбають.
Перехожі весь час жертвують йому щось смачненьке.
Собака цілий день з господарем на свіжому повітрі.
Складніше взимку. Уже сім років, відколи Гайке завів пса,
чоловік не ночує в притулках для безхатченків.
Нам, на жаль, не можна в притулок з собакою.
Це заборонено, бо вони там вважають, що це негігієнічно.
Але я думаю, що собака навіть чистіший за деяких людей.
Так Гайке і Штрольх і живуть без даху над головою.
Безпритульну людину без даху над головою
в Німеччині можна зустріти часто.
А от безпритульного собаку без господаря -
практично неможливо. Усі вони - в притулку для тварин.
У Бонні й околицях знаходять від шести до восьми собак щомісяця,
розповідає співробітниця притулку Реґіна Радемехерс.
Більшість забирають господарі,
від яких пес міг просто втекти під час прогулянки.
Для решти відносно швидко знаходять нових хазяїв.
Утім, собаку з притулку дадуть далеко не кожному.
Якщо людина вранці о 8-й іде на роботу, а ввечері
о 6-й повертається, то такий кандидат собаку в нас не отримає, бо
це надто довго.
Утім, не лише притулки допомогли вирішити проблему собак-безхатченків.
По-перше, кожна собака має бути зареєстрована
та мати чіп, за яким господаря легко встановити.
По-друге, в Німеччині кожен власник собаки сплачує за неї податок.
У Бонні це коштує 150 євро на рік.
По-третє, власники великих та бійцівських собак
повинні укласти страховку на випадок, якщо собака заподіє комусь шкоду.
Навіть без страховки господар несе відповідальність
за поведінку собаки і в разі чого має покрити збитки.
По-четверте, у багатьох містах Німеччини господарі зобов'язані
каструвати тварину, яка вільно бігає по вулиці.
По-п'яте, у Німеччині немає ринків з тваринами.
Тварину можна купити через приватні оголошення або безкоштовно взяти в притулку.
І головне: тварин у Німеччині цінують як членів родини,
із ними ходять по магазинах, їх беруть в ресторани,
вони літають у відпустки. Двері для собак практично всюди відчинені.
Але навіть якщо родина з якихось причин
більше не може утримувати собаку, завжди є вихід.
Замість того, щоб вивозити пса в ліс, можна зателефонувати нам
та просто сказати: ми привеземо собаку.
І це не пов'язано з жодними витратами.
Гадаю, це також профілактика того, щоб собак не викидали.
З кішками ситуація складніша, визнають у притулку.
У Німеччині досі де-не-де зявляються зграї диких котів.
Не кожну кицю, народжену на волі, можна прилаштувати в родину.
Тож притулки виловлюють та каструють їх.
Диких котів відпускають.
Утримування притулку в Бонні, в якому нині мешкає
понад 60 собак і приблизно стільки ж котів,
коштує близько 800 тисяч євро на рік.
За виловлених на вулиці собак доплачує місто. Решта - це пожертви.
Що нас завжди рятує, це не маленькі одноразові пожертви,
які нам, звісно, теж потрібні, а заповіти.
Трапляється, що хтось помирає і каже: я хочу мій будинок заповісти притулку для тварин.
Це великі гроші, які для нас вкрай важливі.
Не менш важливі волонтери, які щодня приходять у притулок
вигулювати собак та гратися з котами.
Майже всі собаки щодня ходять на прогулянку.
Тож найбільше про тварин дбають люди, які
жертвують гроші притулкам, дають домівку безпородним чотирилапим,
не проходять повз безпритульних собак і котів, дарують їм свій час і любов.